let's tell you more about boris johnson
who has pulled out of a major conference
looking at issues around leveling up in
northern england this was to have taken
place in doncaster where our deputy
political editor sam coats has been
waiting patiently for us and you can
bring us some breaking news what's going
on
that's right the applause that you could
hear not for boris johnson because he
is in keeve he has gone to ukraine for
another his second meeting with
president zielinski he traveled this
morning number 10 saying that uh the
news blackout was for security reasons
both for him and for president zielinski
uh this is the second trip that boris
johnson has made
to ukraine since the beginning of the
war he last went on april the 10th uh
presidency spoke to boris johnson on
wednesday night uh then they talked
about the shared determination to defeat
russia uh in this war they talked about
the big problem of food shortages that
the blockade on grain
was causing and he talked about the need
to step up military training here we are
several months into this war and the
russians continue uh to aggressively
assault places uh in uh in particularly
uh in eastern ukraine and that wore very
far from over signs of stagnation in
part the eastern front and it could go
on for a very long time now of course
you had european leaders
mario draghi
and olaf schultz and president macron so
france germany italy's premieres all
going there yesterday you'll have seen
the pictures of those leaders on a train
heading there uh today an announcement
by the european union that the
ukraine is being is now on the path as
it were to european union membership
although it takes some years before it
actually becomes a full member of the
european union boris johnson uh never
wanting to be outflanked by european uh
union leaders when it comes to
ukraine therefore on his way to keeve
this morning in order to meet with
president zielenski i'm told that there
are pictures on their way uh that will
no doubt have been shot i have to say by
staff of boris johnson they're not
letting journalists on these trips so
you get as it were handout photos uh
very much presenting the picture that
boris johnson wants but they are coming
very soon uh as boris johnson continues
his attempt to reset that reset didn't
involve a potentially uh more tricky
appearance today at the northern
research groups conference up here in
doncaster they were expecting to hear
from boris johnson about why he remains
the man to win the red wall why he is
the man who can be trusted barely two
weeks after that vote of no confidence
for 148 tory mps said that they didn't
trust him to take the party into the
next election and a number of quite
tough policy demands from the head of
the nrg jake berry but no no answers on
any of those instead we're going to get
some pictures delivered to us by downing
street of boris johnson in ukraine
coming shortly after he made his second
trip to the embattled war-torn country
since the conflict began